ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ค่ะผู้หญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันนี้กวันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะหวัง
ที่ 31 ค่ะวันที่ 31 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมเดือนมีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพต 2
565 ค่ะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะดีขอ
2022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เปิดเวลา
กี่โมง
ตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น 10 นาทีค่ะค่ะบ่ายสามโมง 10
นาทีนะคะภายใน
อ้า
[เพลง]
ง่วงนอน
3:00 นครูเอ๋จะนอนแล้วเหรอคะครูเอ๋
กิน
จะกินข้าวแล้วก็กิน
กินแล้วก็เคี้ยวกินอิ่มอิ่มก็ฮือ
ๆๆ
เราก็
ง่วงนอน
แล้วทำยังไงครูเอ๋ไม่
ใบง่วงนอนไม่ง่วงนอนงั้นวันนี้ก็นั่งแล้ว
ก็ก็พูดใช่มั้ยปากพูดพูดก็หลับคะๆทักครู
เอ๋รู้สึกหลับยอดนักเรียนนักเรียนก็
ล่ะครูหญิงก็
เพื่อ
หน้าวันนั้นวันนี้ต้อง
ขยับขยับจะได้ตื่นตื่นอาจจะได้ตื่นนะคะ
ว่าชัดไหมเนี่ย
โอเคไหมหากเลยต้องมาใกล้ๆมั้งกูเองมาใกล้
ๆนะกูเองขยับขยับซูมไม่ชัดเลยนะโค๊ะสัก
ครู่นะคะๆค่ะรอได้ค่ะ
โอเคผู้หญิงคะวันนี้เรามาขยับขยับงานคำ
อะไรเส้นหรออ่ะเต้นไม่เต้นไม่เป็น
ผู้หญิงแต่ก่อนจะขยับต้องดูก่อนวันนี้มี
นะเรียนกี่คนวันนี้มีนักเรียน 1  2  3  4
5  6  7  8  9  10  10 คนค่ะ 10 คนยัง
ไม่มีคนที่ 11 ใช่ไหมคะยังไม่มีค่ะคนที่
11 คนที่ 11 อยู่ที่บายหงายหลังหู
โอเคค่ะครูหญิงเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงดูคู๋นะคะดู
คู๋อากูเอเนี่ยมีมือมือมือมือ
มีมือกี่เบอคะนี่มือสองมือค่ะค่ะมีมา 2
มือนะนี้อะไรคะผู้หญิงแหวนแขนนะคะแขนมือ
เออเออมีแผนมือ
ครูเอ๋มีแขนกี่แขนคะ
รู๋มีแขนสองแขนค่ะค่ะสองแขนนะคะแล้วครู
เอ๋แค่นี้นะคะอ่ะอ่ะแขนข้างนี้กับมือใช้
นี้แขนข้างนี้มือครั้งนี้นะคะโอเคกูหญิง
ดูนะคะมือนี้คุณที่นิ้วนิ้วนะคะอ่ะกูเอมิ
นิวกี่นิ้วคะนิ้ว 1  2  3  4  4  5  5  5
นิ้วค่ะถ้านิ้วนะคะแขนข้างนี้มีนิ้ว 5
นิ้วมือ
10,000 มีนิ้วนิ้วนิ้วนิ้วนิ้ว 5 นิ้วนะ
คะนิ้วนิ้วนี้เรียกนิ้วอะไรคะนิ้วนางค่ะ
อ่ะนิ้วนาง
นิ้วนางนิ้วนางครูเอ๋ใส่อะไรคะนิ้วนางครู
เอ๋เอ๋ใส่แหวนค่ะอ่ะใส่แหวนนะคะใส่แหวน
อ่ะงั้นมือนี้มืออะไรคะเมย์สายค่ะอ้าวมือ
ซ้ายมือนี้มืออะไรคะมื้อนี้มือขวาค่ะมือ
ขวานะคะนักเรียนดูนะมีแหวนครูเอ๋นะครูเอ๋
มีแหวนแหวนมือซ้ายเพราะว่าแหวนแต่งงาน
หน้าผู้หญิงทำเพลงได้ไหมคะแต่แฟนแต่แฟน
แต่ๆแต่นแตนกันแต่แอนแต่มันจะบอกขอ
ครูเอ๋แล้วก็แต่งตัวแทนภาย S แต่งงานใส่
แหวนนิ้วนางนะคะนิ้วนางข้างซ้ายมือซ้ายนะ
คะ
มือขวาของครูเอ๋นะผู้หญิงอ่ะคู๋ยกมือขวา
นะคะแล้วครูเอ๋ยกมือซ้ายค่ะผู้หญิงมือขวา
ข้างไหนคะมือขวาครูหญิงใช่ค่ะน่ารักขวากู
ยังยกมือขวาให้นักเรียนเห็นด้วยอ่าผู้
หญิงยกมือซ้าย
ไม่ขวา
ไม่ซ้าย
มือขวามือซ้ายมือซ้าย
ผู้หญิงฟังดีๆนะคะโอเคนักเรียนรู้จักมือ
ซ้ายเอามือขวา
รู้จักมือซ้ายมือขวาจะนิทางด้านนี้เราก็
บอกว่าด้านอะไรคะด้านซ้ายด้าน
ซ้ายทางนี้ราคา
ด้านขวาด้านขวา
บางที่พูดทางซ้ายทางขวาโอเคไหมโอเคค่ะ
ด้านซ้ายทางซ้ายด้านขวาทางขวาโอเคเนาะอ่า
เอาใหม่นะคะผู้หญิงอันนี้อะไรก็ยกมือขวา
ยกมือซ้ายนะคะโอเคอันนี้หน้านะคะผู้หญิง
หน้า
ผู้หญิงหันซ้าย
โอเคค่ะหันกลับ
หันขวา
หันกลับมาอาอ้าโอเคเก่งมากๆจริงๆคุยต้อง
Action ใช่ไหมคุยง่วง
รู๋บอกไงครูหญิง Action ขอหันซ้ายหันกลับ
หันขวาหันกลับนะคะโอเคผู้หญิงต่อไปนะคะมี
ข้างบนนะคะอันนี้ก็คูลล์ชี้นะคะชินิ้วชี้
ข้างบนค่ะอันนี้สี
ข้างอะไรคะช่างล่างข้างล่างข้างบน
ข้างล่างนะคะโอเคอ่ะผู้หญิงดูดูคู๋นะครู
เอ๋ทำอะไร
ครูเองเงยหน้ากูเองไงหน้าตาคู๋มองที่ไหน
คะ
ตาครูเอ๋มองข้างบน
มองจะมามองนี้นะครับมองข้างบนผู้หญิงให้
ครูเอกหลับไหมคะตัวเอกหลับ Bar ค่ะกลับนะ
คะผู้หญิงครูเอ๋มองข้างบนแล้วให้ทำอะไร
ต่อให้ครูเอกก้มหน้าก้มหน้านะก็มหน้ากู
เอมมองที่ไหนคะครูเอ๋มองข้างล่าง
มองข้างล่าง
กุหลาบเงยหน้าเงยหน้าไงหน้านะคะเหนื่อย
หน้าถ้ากูเองมองเงยหน้ามองข้างบนก็อ่ะ
กลับมาก้มหน้าก้มหน้าเงยหน้าเงยหน้า
นะคะโอเคผู้หญิงลองทำบ้างได้ขายหน้า
ก้มหน้าค่ะกลับ
ก็กลับมาก้มหน้าก้มหน้าโอเคนะคะ
มีไงหน้าก้มหน้าไงหน้าน่ะดูข้างบนก้มหน้า
ดูข้างล่างนะคะก็ข้างบนข้างล่างข้างซ้าย
ข้างขวา
ทางซ้าย
ด้านซ้ายด้านขวา
เหมือนกันนะคะขาทางพูดทางซ้ายข้างซ้าย
ด้านซ้ายโอเคนะคะถ้าโอเคเอาอีกนะคะอ่า
ซ่อมอะไรอีกไหมคะทำทำผู้หญิงพยักหน้า
ผู้หญิงใส่หัว
นะคะๆพญาผิวหน้า
มันคูเอนถามคู่หญิงคู่หญิงไหมคะเป็นผู้
หญิงใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะอา
ผู้หญิงถามครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหม
คะใช่ค่ะอ่าพยักหน้านะคะ
ครูหญิงว่ายน้ำได้ใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะอ้าไม่ใช่ล่ะคะครูเอ๋ว่ายน้ำได้
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะอ้าว่ายน้ำได้ก็ถ้าใช่พญา
นาคไม่ใช่
สายหน้าหรือบางทีพูดใส่หัวส่ายหน้าเนาะ
สายหน้าหน้าแล้วก็สายหน้านะคะอยากหน้า
ฝ่าย
ท่าน
ผู้หญิงชอบ
กินทุเรียน
มั้ยไม่
ชอบไม่ชอบก็สายหน้านะคะขาไม่น่ะฝ่าย
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบกินทุเรียนไหมคะ
ชอบ
พยากรณ์อาหาร
ให้ใช่ชอบหล่ะคะตามีอะไรอีกรอบมี
ทางซ้ายทางขวาหันซ้ายหันขวา
เงยหน้า
ก้มหน้านะคะ
พยักหน้าขยายหน้าฝ่ายหน้าโอเคค่ะผู้หญิง
นั่งค่ะผู้หญิงนั่งอยู่ค่ะนั่งนะคะโทรเอ๋
เอ๋ยืนค่ะเล่นเพลงชื่นโอเคยืนคุยต้อง
เลื่อนคอมพิวเตอร์ก่อนกูยืนค่ะยืนยืนคู่
หญิงนั่งค่ะ
คุยยืนค่ะผู้หญิงเดินผู้หญิงเดินไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงนั่งคุยอย่างนี้แหละคือคุณหญิง
Action เด้อเดินครูเอ๋เดิน
[เพลง]
เดี๋ยวคู่หญิงกูเอกเดินไปทางไหนเดินไปทาง
ซ้ายเดินไปทางขวาเดินไปข้างหน้าเลยเดิน
ถอยหลัง
ครูเอ๋เดินไปทางซ้ายค่ะครูเอกต้องทำอะไร
ก่อนคะเป็ดต้องหันซ้ายโดเอหันซ้ายเราก็
เดินไปทางซ้ายค่ะ
ไปเดินกลับมาแต่ถ้า
เอ๋ต้องหันหลังไมค์ไปต้องเดินถอยหลังกลับ
มาค่ะถอยหลังเหรอคะผู้หญิงใช้ค่ะอ่ะที่
เดิมเอสหอยล่ะเวจถอยหลังก็กลับมาทำไมคู่
หญิงไม่ให้เขวตลับหลัง
เอ้าจะได้ฟังถอยหลังถอยล่ะ
ไม่ค่ะหยุดหันหันมาทางขวาไหมคะขวาโอเคกู
เห็นนั่งได้ไหมคะพี่เอ๋นั่งค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ
ไม่เอาเก้าอี้มาก่อนกูเองนั่ง
เห็นนั่งแล้วนะคะโอเคนักเรียนก็รู้จัก
แล้วนะเดี๋ยวถ้าครูครูเอ๋พูดนะคะเดี๋ยว
คุยอีกทำหาแม่กูอ่ะพูดหัน
สุดท้ายผู้หญิงหันซ้าย
อะกลับมาค่ะผู้หญิงหันขวา
หันกว่านะคะผู้หญิงกลับมาค่ะคู่หญิงเงย
หน้า
กลับมาจากผู้หญิงก้มหน้า
โอเคกลับมาค่ะผู้หญิงพยักหน้า
โอเคผู้หญิงใส่หัว
หน้าสายหัวครูหญิงยกมือขวา
ผู้หญิงยกมือซ้าย
ขายครูหญิงขวาหรือย
[เพลง]
ก็ทำโอเคมั้ยโอเคค่ะโอเคก็หญิงหันซ้าย
กลับมาค่ะครูเอ๋เงยหน้าค่ะกลับมาค่ะ
ผู้หญิงพยักหน้าค่ะ
จุดค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ยกมือซ้ายค่ะ
อาโอเคค่ะ
เอามือลงเอามาลงครูหญิง
ตายหัวใจใส่หน้าค่ะใส่หน้า
หยุดถ้าหยุดๆครูเอ๋หันขวาค่ะ
ป่ากลับมาค่ะ
ครูหญิง
ทำอะไรดีอะไรคะทำอะไรคะผู้หญิงนั่งอ่ะ
เก่งเรื่องอยู่ค่ะอ่ะ
นะ
ครูเอ๋ครูเอกยืนค่ะ
ยืนยืน
เป็นเย็น
เห็นนั่งนะคะ
ยืน
นั่งค่ะถุงค่ะพอแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวกูเองไม่
สบาย
ยืนนั่งยืนนั่ง
ๆอาอ่าครูผู้หญิงอะไรดีเดี๋ยวก่อนนะมีผู้
หญิงก้มหน้า
ผู้หญิงเลยหน้า
ผู้หญิงหันซ้าย
ผู้หญิงกลับมาโอเคหันหลัง
อะไรคะโอเคอ่า
ฮะโอเคนักเรียนก็รู้จักเนาะไงหน้าก้มหน้า
หันซ้าย
หันขวา
ยกมือซ้าย
ยกมือขวา
นั่ง
ยืน
สายหน้าพยักหน้าเนาะๆ
เล่นเกม
เล่นเกมยังไงเนี่ยเล่นเกมนะเรามีเวลาเล่น
เกมไหมคะผู้หญิงเรามีเวลาอีก 12 นาทีค่ะ
หมอหมอมีเวลา
12 นาทีเล่นเกมมหายังไงคะครูเอ๋เกม
นักเรียนนะฟ้านี้นะครับฟังแล้วนะเรียนก็
ทำอ๋อ
ครูเอ๋พูดหรอคะให้ครูเอ๋พูดคุยอิงค์พูด
อ่ะบางทีครูเอกพูดบางทีกรูหญิงพูดนะคะ
แล้วนักเรียนเนี่ยดูวีดีโอนักเรียนเรียน
อยู่ฟังแล้วก็ทำแม่
ผู้หญิงไม่ต้อง Action ใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋อ่า
ครูหญิงยังไม่ต้อง Action นักเรียนน่ะดู
อานานๆแล้วคิดว่าจะจำได้
[เพลง]
โอเคค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงดูนะคะดูนักเรียน
10คนนักเรียนทำได้ไหมอ่ะ
ฮะโอเคค่ะอีกหนึ่งครั้งนะคะอ่ะสายนะคะ
ซ้ายขวานะคะ
นักเรียน
ยกมือ
ยกมือยกมือยกมือยกมือ
ยกไหนยกมือซ้าย
ยกเลิกคุยซ้าย
มีนักเรียนยกมือซ้ายไหมคะผู้หญิงมี 5 นัก
เรียนยกมือซ้ายนักเรียนยกมือซ้าย
มือสายมีแหวนเหมือนครูเอ๋ขอนักเรียนแต่ง
งานแล้วมีแหวนอ่ะยกมือซ้ายโอเคค่ะนัก
เรียนยกมือเมื่อไหร่คะผู้หญิง
นึกขวาค่าบ
ถ้า
ผู้หญิงไม่ต้องยกให้นักเรียนจบ
นักเรียนยกมือขวาค่ะ
มันยกมือขวายกมือขวามือหนูโค้งโม่ยกได้
ไหม
ขอได้
ทุกคนเองยกมือขวาอ่อนนักเรียนยกมือขวาได้
นะคะค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมใช่ทำอะไรคะ
เขวให้นักเรียนทำอะไร
นักเรียนผ่านฉัน
หันหันหันซ้ายหันฟ้าหันซ้าย
มือสายหันซ้ายสาย
[เพลง]
เด็กนักเรียนหันซ้ายไหมคะอย่างทำไมบางคน
หันหน้าหากันค่ะ
โอเคนักเรียนหรรษาว้าย
ว้ายครูเอ๋ณตึกสายผู้หญิงก็เลยทำหน้าหา
กันดูนะคะๆ
ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิงให้นักเรียนทำอะไรคะให้
นักเรียน
เงยหน้า
เงย
หน้า
หน้าหน้าเนี่ยนะหน้า
เงย
ไปนักเรียนเงิน
ดูข้างบนอ่านเงยหน้า
เหนื่อยนะค่ะไงหน้าเอ้ยไงๆโอ้วนักเรียน
ทุกคนเงยหน้า
เย็นยิ่งว่าชาเธอเก่งมาก
ครูเอ๋จะให้นักเรียนทำอะไรคะผู้หญิง
เหนื่อยหน้าใช่ไหมกู a ให้นักเรียนก้ม
หน้าค่ะโห
โกงหน้าก้มหน้าดู
ร้องหนึ่ง
โอเคนักเรียนก้มหน้าก้มหน้า
นักเรียนเก่งราชา
ผู้หญิงให้นักเรียนทำอะไรคะให้นักเรียน
ค่ะยักษ์หน้า
พยัก
ใช่ไหมค่ะยักษ์หน้า
ใช่ใช่พยักหน้าพยักหน้า
นะเรียนพยักหน้าค่ะครูหญิง
แต่ถ้าเรียนบอกใช่ค่ะใช้ครับอ่ะครูเอ๋ให้
นักเรียนทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋ให้นักเรียน
สายหน้า
ป่ายหน้าต้องหน้าสิฝากไฟล์หน้า
ไม่ชอบ
ผู้หญิงไม่บอก
ได้ไหมนักเรียนได้ไหมโอ้นักเรียนทำได้
ส่ายหน้านะๆส่ายหน้าได้นะคะ
ผู้หญิงลิงอ่ะใช่
ครูหญิงที่นักเรียน
ยกมือซ้ายยกมือขวา
ผู้เอกก็เก็บตั้งค่า
ให้นักเรียนยกมือซ้ายยกมือขวานักเรียน
โอ้วนักเรียนคำได้ผู้หญิง
เก่งยกมือซ้ายยกมือขวายกสองมือนะคะอันนี้
ยอมแพ้
Minecraft นักเรียนยกมือซ้ายแล้วก็ยกมือ
ขวาค่ะนักเรียนยกมือขวายกมือซ้ายผิดนะคะ
ยกมือซ้ายแล้วก็ยกมือขวานะไทยค่ะครูเอ๋
ครูเอ๋ให้นักเรียนทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋อยากให้
นักเรียน
ยืนค่ะนักเรียนต้องขึ้น
ยืนค่อยยืนยืนๆ
อ๋อรู้แล้ว
เคยบอกขอบคุณค่ะลูกขึ้นค่าตัวเองนักเรียน
ยืนไหมคะรื่นนักเรียนยืนนะคะ
[เพลง]
ครูหญิงอยากให้นักเรียนทำอะไรคะนักเรียน
ยืนอยู่ใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้
ยืนคุยยืนเป็นเพื่อนอ่ะนักเรียนยืนครู
หญิงให้นักเรียน
/ ซ้าย
ฐานซ้าย
นักเรียนพันซ้ายพันๆซ้ายซ้าย
ผู้หญิงนักเรียนหันซ้ายแล้วเดี๋ยวผันหน้า
หรือหันตัวหันทั้งหน้าทั้งตัวไปทางซ้าย
โอเคนะแต่ถ้านักเรียน
หันซ้ายราคาหันซ้าย
นักเรียนหันซ้ายแล้วให้นักเรียน
หันกลับ
ให้นักเรียนได้ยินมั้ยหันหันหันหลังกลับ
เหรอคะได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงหันหลังกลับ
เนี่ยหันทางซ้ายหันทางขวา
ได้ค่ะหันหลังกลับนักเรียนจะหันหลังกลับ
ภาณุสละให้เอาเค
ไม่มีอันหลังกลับให้นักเรียนฉันซ้ายค่ะ
หันซ้าย
ให้นักเรียนนั่งนักเรียนจะก็พี่เอกนั่งๆ
อ้าวก็กูเองบอกทำไมอ่ะกูแอคชั่น
สั้นให้นักเรียนดู
ลืมคู๋ลืมนะคะลืมนะคะมีโปรเออยากให้นัก
เรียนทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋อยากให้นักเรียน
ลุกแล้วก็ยืนยืนยืนๆ
อาใครนักเรียน
ผันขวาค่ะนักเรียนหันขวาหันทั้งหันหน้า
แล้วก็หันตัวเหรอคะอ่าหันหน้าหันตัวทาง
ขวาหันขวานี่แล้วก็ให้นักเรียนเดินทางค่ะ
ออมเดิน
เดินๆเดินไปทางขวาเดินไปทางขวาเดินไปทาง
ขวัญเดินหยุดค่ะ
นัดแล้วทำอะไรต่อ
ถอยหลังกลับค่ะถอยหลังถอยดูหนังถอยหลัง
หยุดค่ะ
นักเรียนหันซ้าย
หันซ้าย
นั่งค่ะนักเรียนนั่งนั่งนะคะครูเอ๋ก็นั่ง
นะคะนั่ง
เหนื่อย
หน้า
เก่งมากเพราะว่าวันนี้ครูเอ๋ให้นักเรียน
เนี่ยทำเยอะๆถ้ายกมือซ้าย
ยกมือขวา
หันซ้าย
หันขวา
เงยหน้าดูข้างบน
ก้มหน้าดูข้างล่าง
แล้วก็อะไรนะเว้ยสายหน้าใครยักษ์หน้านะ
เมื่อคืน
นั่ง
เดินค่ะแล้วก็ถอยหลังแต่ว่าหลีกนักตอนนี้
ทุกคนเหนื่อย
เหนื่อย
พักก่อนใช่ครูเอกตื่นแล้วเพราะว่าเหนื่อย
พักเบรดื่มน้ำนะคะ
ผู้เอกก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้า
ได้ค่ะ 555 สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะผู้
หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย